welche Alternativen gibt es eigentlich
zum Einsatz von Treibhausgas SF6 in
Windrädern dafür schauen wir uns mal an
wie SF6 in anderen Anwendungen ersetzt
wurde seit 2007 ist der Einsatz von SF6
in Autoreifen und schaltschutzscheiben
Verboten als Alternative wird vor allem
Luft eingesetzt revolutionär und auch in
Schaltanlagen z.B in Windrädern kann man
ebenfalls Luft und Vakuum verwenden um
Kurzschlüsse zu verhindern dafür müsste
man die Anlagen teils etwas größer bauen
oder man setzt Feststoffe ein experten
rechnen damit dass SF in bestimmten
Schaltanlagen bald EU-weit verboten wird
aber auch wenn SF6 klimaschädlich ist
sollten wir uns bewusst machen dass SF6
kein spezifisches Problem der
Windenergie ist SF6 ist in allen
möglichen Schaltanlagen verbaut wir
sollten uns um Alternativen bemühen und
dafür sorgen dass die Industrie sich
nicht mehr nur selbstkontrolliert wo es
vermeidbar ist sollte SF6 verboten
werden und mit den Alternativen sind wir
schon auf einem ganz guten Weg aber